we caught our bait right here these are
minnows that we caught with a net
in the re in the in the creek out here
we save them here in this minnow bucket
and then
i want to take this little bag baby and
put it right in the seam right there
where that water is coming off of this
river this little creek
so that's my goal
look at that
this is 100 mother nature right here
baby
100 mother nature
these are
all natural fish
no preservatives
nothing
look at that
i'm upstairs baby
i'm upstairs
now what do i do
ah take give him a little hug there and
see if you can get him out all right
fired up
he's fired up dude he probably
come on get in there
oh
let's go boy i'm upstairs look he got
that little one on the uber like he's
driving uber
this uber xl that little one trying to
sneak a ride baby
you got to be hungry if you you bite you
don't even eat the food
you just get fork only
oh my god this went through his brain i
need help
damn
damn he's strong bro
this one out the bible bruh this one's
strong bro
damn
look he's dancing bro like he's from
atlanta baby this one's really dancing
all right
nope
stronger than that oh
let's go
i'm on stairs buddy
we caught him clean baby
started go fund me for this little cliff
palette i'm about to give him but hey
that's all right
that's the lord baby